the honored wat wat wat is long gone
gene watches have 110 World's Fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece lon gene the world's most
honored watch is made and guaranteed by
the lawn gene with no watch company it's
time for the launching conosco the
television journal of the important
issues of the hour tour show you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrono scope mr. Elliot Haines an
editor of united nations world and mr.
henry hazlitt editor of The Freeman and
contributing editor of Newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is dr. Lyle J Hayden formerly chief of
the agricultural section of ECA and
presently program director of the near
East foundation the opinions expressed
are necessarily those of the speaker dr.
Hayden you've just returned from Iran
I'd like to know what the near east
foundation has been doing lately there
Nerys foundation is engaged in a program
of rural improvement and our objective
is to improve the standard of living
among the peasants in rural iran we hope
to do this in the form of a
demonstration which will be accepted and
put into practice by not only the
iranian government by the peasants
themselves I suppose automate clear
though that the near East foundation is
a private organization private
philanthropic office organization has
nothing to do with eca that is right
it's a private organizations responsered
by individual contributions
and it has its motto to help the people
who help themselves through greater
learning could you give us some idea dr.
Hayden of those contributors are well
for the most part they're people without
a great deal of money on a judge I don't
know who they are but the average
contribution runs around ten or twelve
dollars so this is more or less the
common people of America helping the
common people of Iran that's the nice
thing about our program what sort of
relation would your program have 2.4 I
don't mean whether it has an informal
relationship but I mean how does it
compare and what it does it tries to do
perhaps you should say what the
relationship this point for have to our
program well that's all I thought we
were going the 4.4 foot 4.4 was
inaugurated but actually it's accomplish
the same thing we're both trying to help
the backward peoples of the world help
themselves did you give us some idea dr.
Hayden of just how backward Iran is say
for example what their agricultural
methods are the average Iranian peasant
farmer has a wooden plow he has a float
that is a drag but eight feet long that
she fixed the point of the plow in and
perhaps he has a half interest in an ox
outside of that he has nothing but hand
tools and that requires an awful lot of
correction i imagine doesn't yes it does
it means with these very crude
implements he can only handle about
seven and a half to as much as 15 acres
that's all the land he can physically
get over during the short growing season
to have available does it well I'd like
to bring up a question of this nature a
lot of people think a lot of business
men who've come back from the so-called
underdeveloped countries say that the
chief need of those countries is private
risk capital private foreign risk
capital and that when this money is
handed out let's say under point for ECA
or our United States government then
these countries the governments of these
countries won't do the things that are
necessary to attract foreign capital to
make their country too
to define capsule and that until they do
that they won't be developed and I'd
like to have you speak to that point
that is a very difficult point and I
think it's due to the fact that many of
these government's many of the
governments of these backward areas are
relatively unstable themselves until the
Nationals of a country who have well are
willing to invest in that country's
resources you can hardly ask a foreigner
to send money in but don't doesn't the
government have to make conditions
attractive for the domestic investor
before it's likely to make them
attractive for the foreign investor
that's true it should make it attractive
for the domestic investor and I think
that most countries are trying to do
that they've made considerable progress
in that respect dr. Hayden getting back
to Iran for a second I understand that
no matter how much technical assistance
of the type that your foundation renders
to of foreign countries that they do
need a certain amount of the type of
capital mr. Haslett mentioned and Iran
especially needs a resumption of her oil
revenues that she lost recently would
you concur in that yes very definitely
it seems as though Iran is almost on the
verge of bankruptcy I don't know where
they'll get to foreign exchange and less
they can sell their oil well now do you
think that there's a possibility that
the British and the Iranians will patch
up their differences now do you think so
what do you think there's any likelihood
of a settlement through this world bank
arrangement that's been spoken of I
think that's the most hopeful type of
solution that has been suggested so far
do you think there's any real
possibility of its being acceptable both
to the British and to the Iranians i
think it is yes i think that probably
some type of arrangement like that
perhaps with modifications is about the
only solution that i can see i
understand that the loss of oil to the
west has already been made up in other
areas of the near east though so that
it's actually just a question marantz
welfare that's right that's unfortunate
for me Ron's point of view well just how
important is your ran to the to the west
that case what I consider it is very
important because there is a great
reserve of oil in that area and we are
interested in the oil reserves and if
Iran should go through a revolution if
some foreign power should take over
control of Iran it's quite conceivable
that they could easily take over control
of all the rest of the oil-producing
area around the Persian Gulf and that
area produces or has potential reserve
some 40 or 60 percent of the world's
reserve oil supply which might be needed
some time which might be needed
sometimes well do you think we've been
following a very good policy in the near
East you mean aren't policy on policy
perhaps I might ask that answer that
question by asking one as the typical
arab night and that would be to say what
is our foreign policy in the near the
arab levels of the app about that it
seems that we have one time followed one
course of action and another time
thought another we have told the arab
that we were their friends and that we
wanted to help them and then we seem to
help the countries or country that was
taking their territory away from them at
least they were afraid that they would
be that is a reason well as the Arab
make any comparison between our
treatment of them and our treatment
let's say Israel very definitely so in
the recent the allotment of funds under
TCA there is said well you are giving 50
million dollars to 4 million people and
fifty million dollars to 40 million
people and we are the 40 moving and we
think that's not and an actual
distribution of this aid for coming back
to the work of the near East foundation
just what would be a typical project
what would be a typical concrete project
that you've been doing lately well I one
of the things that we have done is to
encourage farmers to improve their
poultry breeds and just recently when I
was
around the last time I was privileged to
observe an exchange of improved birds in
fact they were very nice barred rock
roosters for those that the villagers
raised our approach women went to the
village with enough roosters to exchange
one nice rooster for every native roots
to the head an interesting thing
happened there he's children and ladies
men are bringing the Roosters up and I
saw one woman that had a very small
rooster and pretty soon I looked around
and she was not there then before the
end of the line reached the truck she
was back but she had to the small
rooster and a small hint when they asked
her why she was bringing the hen she
said my chicken was so small that I
thought I'd had to give to one of these
nicely do you think dr. Hayden that the
absentee land owner problem in Iran is
one that has to be solved yes I think
that type of land tenure system must be
solved must be improved eventually is
that done by educating the landowner or
or by putting political and pressure on
him or how you've stated is a very nice
way educating the landowner to show him
that it's necessary for this land reform
to come about in other words that he
must take more interest in his peasants
help them and share a greater amount of
the wealth living you think that you can
do that that they will listen to you of
course not all of them that there are
many landowners who are quite willing to
improve a lot of their people they know
that that's simply good insurance they
must do that dr. Hayden I'd like to
switch to Europe for our second and ask
you something about your ECA experiences
do you believe that the our policy of
was well handled in giving the vast sums
we did to Europe nineteen forty seven
eight and nine I think that very
definitely we were doing the right thing
by providing economic aid to Europe
perhaps I would agree with Senator tack
when I say when he said that he bleed in
foreign aid but not so much
I think I agree like today Hayden is a
final question I'd like to ask you what
do you think is the most important thing
that America needs need to do in the
near East today I think the most
important thing is to get the confidence
of the near East people we need to help
them straightforwardly and honestly to
improve their lot I think the stood by
technical assistance American know-how
with Americans going in and working with
them at the grassroots level is the best
single thing we can do well thank you
very much dr. Hayden for being with us
tonight thank you the editorial board
for this edition of the lawn gene
proneness co was mr. Elliot haynes and
mr. Henry Hazlitt our distinguished
guest was dr. Lyle j Hayden program
director of the near East foundation